Palacio de San James Carlos es
proclamado rey a su lado Camila Parker
bowles su gran amor en todo este proceso
me he sentido profundamente alentado por
el apoyo de mi amada esposa
luego de décadas tumultuosas bajo los
reflectores de la prensa Rosa Camila se
convierte en reina a los 75 años y con
el 48% de popularidad
la mujer más odiada de Reino Unido
titulaban los medios Camila se erigió
como el antagonista en el matrimonio
entre Carlos y la princesa Diana de
gales pero el amor entre la obra rey y
Camila inició hace más de 50 años
iniciaba la década de los 70 cuando la
joven Camila shant se casó con el
brigadier del ejército británico Andrew
Parker Bells dos hijos serían producto
de la relación Carlos entonces príncipe
de gales fue padrino de Tom el hijo
primogénito de Camila el matrimonio era
cercano al príncipe Andrew y Carlos
jugaban por los juntos
las cámaras ya captaban en 1972 el
Triángulo amoroso que se estaba formando
al margen de los campos de Polo Camila y
Carlos intimaban Camila con una
formación de posgrado en la prestigiosa
escuela monferal de Suiza y lecciones de
literatura francesa destacaban los
círculos de la alta sociedad londinense
y su familia pudiente y bien relacionada
ayudaba pero no se perfilaba como
miembro de la realeza Una institución
considerada arcaica y representante de
la iglesia anglicana que no permitiría
un escándalo extramarital
en 1981 la corona británica encontró la
princesa adecuada para Carlos Jana
Spencer
durante años Camila y Carlos se
mostraron distantes ante las cámaras
pero eran confidentes en privado en 1993
un año después de la separación entre
Diana y Carlos y uno antes del proceso
de divorcio de Camila y Andrew la prensa
publicó una serie de conversaciones
privadas entre Camila y el príncipe de
gales que revelaban el alcance su amorío
siguieron años difíciles para Camila
víctima de la dureza mediática la
trágica muerte de Diana en 1997 reforzó
su imagen negativa pero los asistentes
de la realeza se dedicaron a reconstruir
la imagen de Carlos y Camila
[Aplausos]
en 1999 hicieron una primera aparición
pública juntos y en 2005 se casaron en
los años posteriores la crítica de la
prensa menguó debido al firme apoyo de
la familia real a Camila pero una parte
del pueblo sigue siendo implacable